le guen on le sait les attentats de
paris ont lieu à trois semaines du
premier tour des régionales c'est un
contexte politique très particulier est
ce que dans ces conditions tragiques la
campagne des régionales peut reprendre
certains disent le ps notamment on va
reprendre lundi prochain ce que ça vous
paraît raisonnable
d'abord la campagne officielle commence
lundi prochain et nous sommes et nous
avons décidé personne d'ailleurs n'a
demandé à ce qu'on remporte cette
échéance sera étaient en recul comme
suez était un recul aussi sur la com 21
devant la menace des terroristes est
donc une victoire des terroristes donc
nous sommes debout et nous respectons
nos échéances et donc la loi et donc le
fait que la campagne officielle commence
lundi proche de faire de la politique
dans ces moments là et je me range on
peut faire de la politique je pense que
simplement la manière dont on le fait
est totalement différente c'est pour ça
que je pense que la manière dont le
gouvernement et cette majorité le fait
avec un souci de dignité de
rassemblement et la bonne façon de faire
je ne crois pas que les polémiques un
peu stérile et procès d'intention et
c'est très utile il n'y a pas besoin de
jouer
l'agressivité pour montrer des
différences qui peuvent exister mais
pourquoi pourquoi partir dans des
discours qui viennent plutôt alimentée
la menace pourquoi les divisions surtout
chez les françaises s'est passé pas
utile justement quelles conséquences sur
le scrutin est ce que vous craignez que
ces événements fasse le lit du front
national
est ce que c'est une crainte que qui
existe chez vous la menace du front
national existaient malheureusement
maintenant depuis des mois et des années
la réalité donc je ne veux pas je ne
sais pas ce que comment réagiront les
connais sarkozy dit que ça pourrait
influencer le scrutin en faveur du front
national
écoutez je lui laisse la responsabilité
de ses propos
dans cette période moi je n'ai qu'une
chose à dire aux français c'est que il
faut aller voter
ils veulent vivre ils sont fiers de la
république alors qu'ils votent
voilà c'est toujours espérer un sursaut
de participation justement sur cette
élection que les gens se mobilisent dans
une sorte de bruit sursaut républicain
je le crois je crois j'entends bien que
certains de nos compatriotes se disent
que les politiques mises en place ont
pas assez efficace il ya des déceptions
il ya d'impatience il ya des
interrogations il ya de
l'incompréhension
tout ça existe mais maintenant ces
événements nous rappellent ce que nous
sommes nous sommes des citoyens c'est à
nous d'agir et ce moment le vote sera
aussi une manifestation très forte de
mobilisation républicaine et noël j'en
appelle moi par la sécurité ou contre la
sécurité
non je ne crois pas que qui peut être
contre la sécurité
donc je pense pas qu'il ya deux camps
qu'ils soient pour ou contre la sécurité
je pense que chacun doit évoquer selon
ses conceptions très bien selon ses
inclinaisons du moment mais en fonction
de l'idée que voter c'est défendre la
république il ya un ministre qui joue un
rôle essentiel cette semaine c'est jean
yves le drian qui supervise
l'intensification de des opérations
contre des chefs il est on l'a presque
oublié peut-être de liste en bretagne
est ce qu'il doit clarifier sa position
en vue de cette élection en désignant
par exemple son dauphin et en promettant
qu'il ne sera pas présent de région
puisque je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que il doit rester
ministre de la défense dans ces
conditions écoutez tout le monde est
d'accord ça très sensible il ya une
seule adresse aux cibles non mais je
j'entends et j'écoute comme vous un
partir les complimente c'est compliqué
ils sont faits et en même temps vous
connaissez aussi les compléments qui lui
sont faits en tant que représentant
emblématique de la bretagne
bon voila moi je pense donc le choix
n'est pas fait mais il n'y a pas
forcément de choix à faire je pense que
d'ores et déjà jean yves le drian est à
la fois un excellent pour ne pas dire
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire le
meilleur ministre de la défense qui a eu
la vème république et de l'autre côté il
est le leader emblématique de la
bretagne est sans doute lui puisque tout
haut depuis aussi vous souhaitez que
giresse
voilà vous souhaitez qui reste métiers
de la défense en tout cas il est
pleinement aujourd'hui voilà chaque
chose suffit son honneur mais en tout
cas ne demandons pas à jean yves le
drian de ne pas être ce qu'il est il est
à la fois le leader emblématique de la
bretagne et il est à la fois le meilleur
très vite pourtant pour pour terminer on
vient d'apprendre ce matin qu'il y aura
une cérémonie nationale d'hommage aux
invalides
vendredi prochain c'est ce sera une
cérémonie sans précédent on attend
évidemment toutes les familles des
victimes qui seront très nombreuses
peut-être aussi des blessés est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus sur cette
cérémonie et et surtout sur le ce que ça
va représenter 30 sont autant de temps
réuni autant de gens réunis aux
invalides pour ça ça ne servait il
fallait il faut évidemment qui est une
manifestation nationale est une
cérémonie nationale ne sont pas il ya
tellement de victimes que tout ça
évidemment les enterrements
appartiennent aux familles mais il ya
besoin de réunir la nation dans un
moment de deuil et ce sera ce moment là
je le crois que ce sera quelque chose de
très fort